joe moeller and kristen drummond trying
to figure out exactly how this all
happened
kristen what's the latest on the
investigation now
well denise what we've been told four
men and one woman died according to
nevada highway patrol
they were hit here on u.s 95 south wall
riding towards searchlight
during a 130 mile birthday bike ride
that started at the end resorting casino
this morning the crash shut down the
southbound lanes for
six hours nevada highway patrol says a
group of more than 10
cyclists were riding on the highway then
at around 9 30
a box truck driving the same direction
went into their lane
now the reason why remains unknown but
impairment is not suspected
a couple troopers are telling me this
crash is one of the more horrific ones
they've responded to when you hear the
details of it
just as everyone here with me right now
you hear those details that's why we're
all out here today it sounds horrible
and it's cool
nhp says a support and gear car also
known as a
sag vehicle was accompanying the cyclist
the safety car was
in between the riders during the crash
the driver
was hospitalized now the driver of the
box truck
did stop and was not hurt and troopers
say that the driver was cooperating with
the investigation
reporting live on u.s 95 in between
boulder city and searchlight kristen
drummond 8 news now
kristin thank you cycle